welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series
i am your host greg knuckles uh thanks
for coming back to this
the eighth installment of the fireside
chat series
uh if this is the first one you're
tuning into and you're expecting
a lot of discussion of fitness and
science
and the things we cover on the normal
episodes
uh you're not gonna find it here we're
just gonna
talk about fun things that our listeners
have suggested
these are uh at least supposed to be
pretty fun light-hearted episodes
where we discuss uh off-topic subjects
so uh yeah that's what we're doing here
and i figure we'll
get on into it how are you doing today
trex
i am doing well and quick uh quick
message for those who have caught
our previous fireside chats the last
couple times
our off topic topics have been very on
topic
but but this time we actually are
uh getting away from that stuff very off
topic today
yes hopefully i mean we'll probably
accidentally find a way to get on topic
i'm i'm looking at
i'm looking at the uh the second
question here uh
in some of the notes you've jotted down
so we'll see what happens
uh but yeah let's let's get right on
into it uh
the first question that came in from one
of our listeners
is uh what is the best way to motivate
yourself
or i guess how we're going to answer it
how do we go about motivating ourselves
so motivation's tough and and i don't
purport to have any expertise on this
like i'd
i've never read the motivation
literature
but i am a person who has at times
needed to become motivated
and what has always worked for me is
this is kind of a cop-out but just
trying to limit
how much effortful motivation i really
have to conjure up
so um you know i think we're pretty
lucky
given that most of the tasks we have to
do
are things that interest us and things
that we believe should be done
like we don't have some like higher up
boss who's just telling us to do busy
work
yeah aside from lindsay yeah um who can
be very tough
but but no i mean so most of the stuff
we do we're passionate about it and we
think it really ought to be done
otherwise we wouldn't be doing it so
that stuff's pretty easy
but you know going back to times where i
have
needed to kind of dig deep and figure
out how to how to get myself in the
mindset to get
something done what i like to do is kind
of reframe the task
and find a motivation that makes sense
to me
so like if you're not motivated
about doing the task for its sake you
know so it's something that you're not
passionate about maybe you don't even
think it really should be done
you have to find a way that it makes
sense for you to actually be doing it
and so sometimes it might be honestly uh
you might be kind of deluding yourself
into thinking that it makes sense but
like for me that's always been the way
to do it i have to understand
that for me personally there's a reason
why it makes sense for me to be
working on this um and yeah
for me that's been the easiest way to do
it and i can usually find some
justification like it's better for me to
do this
than to not do it or to procrastinate
and so however you have to kind of weave
a narrative to make that work
that's been my go-to it's pretty similar
for me
um on a day-to-day basis there aren't
that many things i have to do that i
just really really don't want to do
um but yeah for for the things that i
don't have that much intrinsic
motivation to do that
that i have to uh you know just
put the nose to the grindstone and get
done um
early on in my fitness career i guess
uh the biggest motivation was probably
to not wind up living under a bridge
somewhere
um it's so like
i mean i've talked about this on the
podcast before but fresh out of school
didn't have much money weren't making a
ton of money
um and so especially for like getting
the coaching business off the ground
uh a lot of that was just like look
i need to make some money or things are
gonna be really tight
um and also like we didn't understand
how
tax law worked at all so i was just
dreading april coming i was like
[ __ ] we need to make a lot of money
because i have no idea
how big the tax bill to uncle sam's
gonna be
um so like we had that sense of
impending dread of like we don't know
how much money we need to make but like
there's a good chance that we'll be
homeless in april if we don't make it
so that was
yeah i mean that was that was quite a
motivator early on
um another thing that
i think motivates me quite a bit is just
like the
ability to help people out and
i don't know like i don't i don't really
consider myself
a humanitarian or anything like that um
but like we give a fair amount of money
to charity and
uh like essentially once
our our basic needs are met and we're
saving and putting away the amount of
money that we want to make
um beyond that like we just donate most
of it to charity
um and so like yeah as far as like
business stuff goes
um the more money we make the more money
we have to help other people
um and that feels good you know
uh and then the last thing and honestly
this is probably the biggest one um
i am a very goal-oriented person
um and i like to tick things off my
to-do list that just feels very good to
me
and so if there's a task that i really
really don't want to do
um this is
this is an idea i picked up from james
clear
uh declare my conflict of interest here
that is my wife's false
um but i picked this up before she
worked for him
um so like the idea is just like
just getting started on something so i
think the
example he uses in in his article is
like okay like if you need
if you know you need to go for a run uh
but you're not motivated to do it
like just lace your shoes up and say i'm
just gonna take five minutes and go on a
little jog
and five minutes later if you're not
just like utterly hating it
yeah just keep jogging you know and if
five minutes in you do utterly hate it
and it's just like
really not something you have motivation
to do just quit
and at that point you've only wasted
five minutes but
you know there is a chance that once you
get going you'll just keep going
and that's uh that is pretty much how i
am
like it's really really hard for me to
get started on stuff sometimes
but then once i get started uh i i just
zone out
and just keep working until it's done um
so yeah just for me like if i can
just force myself to get over that hump
and get something started
generally i can keep doing it even if i
don't find it particularly
fun or pleasant yeah i was thinking you
know
my answer it might make more sense if i
give an example
you know so i talked about just
convincing yourself that something
that's not worth your time is definitely
worth your time
and you know or time and effort so i
took a course during my phd that was on
muscle signal processing and like at
that point in my phd i
knew what kind of methods i used in my
research
and that just wasn't it i didn't do
muscle signal processing
um but i was like you know what i could
do like i have to take this class anyway
and i have to use the software that i
think is ridiculous
i'm gonna duplicate all of my homework
assignments in r
just to prove a point to someone i don't
know who
nobody listened because i was like dude
this is way better than r but like
it's just like finding a way to take
something where you're like wow this is
this is not contributing to my anything
i'm going to use in the future but like
okay but this will be fun and i'll prove
a point to myself i guess and i'll pick
up some skills that might actually be
useful because
the more the more i do an r the better i
get with it
so it's just that kind of thing of like
reframing but but like you said like you
mentioned like oh
the more i do the more i can give to
charity it's the same kind of concept of
like
it's no longer about the task
necessarily but like
doing this task brings me closer to
doing something else that i really value
right you know what i mean yeah and on a
day-to-day basis as well
um if there's something i i don't
particularly
want to do but i need to get done uh
when i get it done
i know so i i
am like a a classic procrastinator um
but like one of the things that helps a
lot is
i have a lot of things i like to do when
i'm not working and also
when i have something big hanging over
me i just enjoy my time that i'm not
working
less because i know when i get back to
work there's still this task that i need
to get done
that i hate um and so like
part of it for me is just purely hedonic
as well where
it's just like there's this thing on my
to-do list i [ __ ] hate it
but the hours of the day that i spend
not working i
enjoy them less and they're less
pleasurable and less fun
because this thing is still hanging over
me so just like
if i want to enjoy life i need to get
this [ __ ] done
um and that's that's i think the biggest
thing i use as a motivator to start
tasks that i don't particularly want to
do
yeah i didn't even think i've never
thought of it that way but i literally
did that this morning like i was telling
you i
i woke up about four hours earlier than
i planned to
but there's been this task hanging over
my head that i'm like i gotta do this
so yeah this whole morning i was doing
that exact thing because it's been like
the time i'm not working i'm thinking
like i gotta do that at some point
you know yeah speaking of doing things
you wanna talk about what happens behind
the scenes
is stronger by science sure let's do it
why don't you kick off
uh this particular question yeah so uh
one of
our listeners asked what happens behind
the scenes of stronger by science
um we're a small scrappy company that is
trying to compete with the big boys i
guess and
the only way we get that done is through
massive amounts of verbal and physical
abuse like
uh sometimes you got the stick sometimes
you got the carrot
and i don't particularly like carrots um
it's interesting because like
myself eric and lindsey are co-owners of
stronger by science so we don't
necessarily have a boss that everyone
reports to
um so it's less like someone with a
stick
using it on everyone else and more just
like a circle of stick usage
um so yeah it's a it's a very toxic but
also productive work environment i would
say
and i wouldn't have it any other way
yeah there's a certain amount of
anger and animosity and discomfort that
really puts you in the sweet spot
in terms of of creativity yeah there's
a lot of tension and no one feels
comfortable really letting their guard
down
i do my best work when i don't have
burning resentment
because you know that's that's a
distraction you don't want that when
you're working
but just like low-level saving
resentment that's uh
that that's what really puts me in the
right mind space to get stuff done
perfect yeah no realistically
you know like you said it's a small
company right i mean there's there's the
three of us plus oswald
plus household oswald the dog um
most of the time i'd say we're sitting
at the desk and
looking over papers that we're gonna
cite in an article or maybe we're
writing about
it for mass or whatever the case may be
and
invariably we'll start complaining
pretty frequently yeah i mean sometimes
we'll come across something that's
really good
and we'll say like wow that's pretty
cool good stuff
but we we do a lot of low level uh
complaining
you know not super worked up or upset
about it but just like oh
this again yeah and uh yeah we you know
we talked about we're complaining with a
sense of resignation
yeah because like all of the [ __ ] we see
we've seen a million times before and
we're like oh
it's uh it's our good buddy confusing
standard errors and standard deviations
you know it's it's like an old friend
that you don't particularly like
exactly but one of the things so this is
my first
uh job out of school right so like i did
undergrad master's phd all in a row
and then started doing this one of the
things that i find really interesting
about our day-to-day operations
is because there's so few of us it's
like every person has this weird mixture
of
input on really big picture stuff but
also
handles like really mundane tasks like
just the the mixture of huge big picture
stuff
and really tiny insignificant detail
stuff
is it's such a broad range of tasks that
we do
um and even just like the tasks
themselves right so like
uh obviously like writing and
coaching and audio editing and like
just the the different hats that you
wear when you work at such a small
operation is is really fun i think i
like being able to
have a really rich mixture of tasks that
are so different
you know yeah for sure i mean i'm i'm
very introverted
i'm not gonna lie i kind of like when i
can just edit some audio for a few hours
and just kind of block everything else
out you know what i mean
but yeah i mean that's that's the day to
day right we just kind of read research
and write stuff and do audio and
that's it yeah pretty much um i mean
if someone's interested in what my
day-to-day looks like
uh i'm generally working by
9 9 30 and then i use the morning
when you know my brain's kind of getting
woken up and i'm getting in a groove
to uh just like respond to stuff
i have a big list of places where
people might try to get in contact with
me um so
you know email facebook messenger
instagram twitter
reddit uh see if people have like
requested any of my papers on
researchgate
uh look at comments and see if we're
getting
a lot of uh like back like links
from other websites like just checking
website traffic and comments
um and so like i do all of that in the
morning uh
and so if uh if i
ever sent you a message and seemed like
i was in a bad mood
i probably was i'm not a morning person
uh
i i am generally not as
annoyed or surly as i might come across
in uh
online communication i mean even
even outside of the morning hours though
that is your kind of
your digital communication style in
messages
yeah you do tend to be a little bit more
short
with your language so that the first few
times that
that we started like interacting via
like text message or facebook message
i was like damn greg's like is he upset
in general or is he mad at me
like i didn't do anything but that's
just kind of the way you
you talk well so
yes uh reason for that is um
so i i do that stuff from about 9 9 30
to 12.
and so i've got like two and a half
three hours
of just people to respond to about
random stuff
pretty much every day and uh
you know it's a lot of time and if i
wrote like full long polite responses to
everyone
instead of being two and a half three
hours it would be like five or six
hours uh and and like i just simply
can't do that
and i have like this almost pathological
need
to respond to everyone
um and i think like part of that is
just kind of like how i think it's like
based on my experiences
as a young person who is interested in
fitness and powerlifting
because like you know i would look up to
people and i would have questions for
them or feedback or whatever else
and i get up with them and like you know
eighty percent of the time
they would just like ignore it and you
know
that didn't like ruin my self-concept or
anything but like
i didn't like it it wasn't fun you know
and so like
i tried to not do that to other people
and so
we uh the reason we started
the q a segment of the regular podcast
actually
was so when people ask questions i could
just be like ah
well fill out the q a form and we'll
maybe address it on the podcast
uh i just like forgot about that within
about two weeks
and just went back to responding to
everyone again
but yeah so my online communication
style people do
always think i'm mad at them and i'm i'm
generally not
um but yeah i mean it's just like i have
to be quick and efficient if
i'm going to be able to respond to
everyone who wants a response about
stuff
uh a lot of people say when they meet me
they're surprised at how talkative and
effusive i am because they're just like
whoa this is
this is not the vibe i got from like
chatting with you on instagram
pro tip though if you want me to seem
less annoyed when i'm responding to you
don't message me on instagram don't mess
don't
don't [ __ ] text me uh that might take
a while to get a response i hate texts i
haven't texted you in like
probably two years thank you there's no
point that
um but yeah like anything that
primarily functions on mobile uh so
instagram does have
it you can access messages on desktop
now but like it's still
kind of glitchy i think um but yeah hit
me up on facebook or send me an email
uh i can type a lot more a lot faster
if i have a keyboard than if i have like
a mobile keyboard
[Laughter]
so yeah my my facebook messages are
probably like six times longer than my
instagram messages because
i refuse to type a long message on my
phone
like i'm just not gonna do it yeah
that's fair and i'm not surprised to
hear
what you mentioned like that people are
a little bit surprised when they meet
you in person because
in person you are
very i mean several deviations from
from the the median or the mean when it
comes to just general
jollyness like you are
a far above average jolly fellow
and quite outgoing yeah but your your
online communication style
especially like you mentioned on certain
platforms is very far the other
direction very brusque
yeah very brusque yeah and it's there's
nothing wrong with that
but but i could understand why somebody
would be like what
who did i message online like yeah who
is the intern
who's having a bad day answering these
messages for you yeah no
it's always me responding and i
swear to god i i don't hate you as much
as it seems like i do
that's good to know um you want to talk
about some sports
yeah let's do it let's talk sports oh
actually
i was i started with something and then
got sidetracked oh
um so yeah if you want to know what my
day to day looks like it's
responding to stuff until about noon uh
and then i take like a 30 minute to an
hour lunch break
um where generally i'll eat something
maybe stretch a little bit just kind of
like hang out
and then from 12 30 or 1 until
uh five on a short day six on a long day
um
i try to work on kind of more important
big picture stuff so first half of the
month
that's writing mass uh second half of
the month
that's just like various other things so
the programs we put out like that's i
worked on those during the afternoons
um if i'm like putting a talk together
that's like i'll work on that during the
afternoon um
we're writing some books so like when
other stuff is ticked off my to-do list
like i'll work on my book in the
afternoon
um so yeah like afternoon is kind of
like more
important long-term big picture stuff uh
yeah that's what that's what my days
look like these days
uh and then generally still
maybe like twice a month uh
when linz goes to bed i'll put in
like five or six hours on something
overnight
uh just like if stuff is backed up and i
need to get something done
during school that was probably like
three nights a week
um and now it's like two or three nights
a month and that's
that's very doable for me uh but yeah
that's
kind of what my my work day slash month
looks like
dude when we first started hanging out
regularly
i actually didn't quite know you at all
like that was a that was a don't you
think it's fair to say that was a fully
different version of greg
it was definitely a much more depressed
version
yeah dude yeah you whatever light
is currently behind your eyes was fully
extinguished yeah
i was i was in a dark place
yeah i mean the you were probably
averaging
10 hours of sleep a week uh
during my thesis project yeah yeah
otherwise
yeah otherwise it was probably
averaging four to five hours a night
closer to four
uh but but generally that would take
take the form of just alternating
all-nighters
yeah yeah i'd pull an all-nighter i'd
sleep about eight hours the next night
pull an all-nighter sleep about eight
hours the next night which
which sounds crazy um i actually
felt and functioned way better doing
that than if i just slept four hours
every night
uh because when i do that there's a
like one day of poor sleep i'm i'm
perfectly fine
uh two days like things are quite a bit
worse and then like if i don't recharge
and get a full night of sleep at some
point
it's i just like slowly descend
and it just gets worse and worse on a
day-to-day basis and so
with with the schedule i was keeping
where it was like alternating
sleep all nighter sleep all nighter
basically i'd have one good day one bad
day
uh instead of all bad days um which
you know doesn't sound great but it uh
50 bad days is it turns out fewer bad
days and 100
bad days so it got the job done that
should be like one of those motivational
posters that are supposed to
brighten your day yeah 50 bad days
ain't so bad yeah i mean you know
i i work less now than i think i have
in my entire adult life um i put in
probably 50 hours a week give or take
45.50
during school i was putting in 50
60 on the business uh and then also as a
full-time grad student
yeah and uh it doesn't work out
does not work out all right uh
sports do you want generally yeah in
favor yeah
cool so uh a person asks if you were to
compete in a sport
that was neither a strength sport nor
one of the big four or five spectator
sports of the western world
parentheses football soccer baseball etc
what would it be and why
yeah so i've got two answers um
one would be like so it's hard to be
good at a sport right
so you basically have to decide for
someone like us like
what would you least suck at you know
what i mean like sports are
highly skilled endeavors so which one
would i be
least bad at well it said if you had to
compete in a sport it doesn't
necessarily say
go pro in a sport just compete in it
yeah okay well
my answer still works so the realistic
one would be
wrestling uh i wrestled it's not a big
spectator sport
but it was great i enjoyed it i don't
think i would enjoy it as much now
uh you know time has been unkind
to me i don't know if i still have it in
me
um but it you know it was a fun sport
but man i
when you try to take wrestling to a high
level so like
go watch a high school wrestling
tournament
a lot of points someone's gonna win 14
to six
you know a lot of pins go watch a
college match
like two really good teams three to two
two to one when you get to that level it
becomes
no one makes mistakes it becomes so
difficult to score
a point in any way and so the the really
paradoxical thing about wrestling is the
higher the level gets
the worse it is to watch because it just
looks like a couple people that aren't
doing much but they're actually doing
a billion things impossibly quickly
and with such proficiency that no one
has an opening is that still the case
with you
like i i know a little bit about
wrestling but not much
uh and i feel like i would miss a lot of
the
really cool stuff that people are doing
like as someone like you who knows a lot
about wrestling
is it still boring to watch like that
level of defensive play
so like the wrestling hipster
answer would be oh the highest level's
the best
it's the nuances and the intricacies but
realistically no man i like seeing the
fireworks
like what's really fun is two people
that are skilled but sloppy
two really skilled wrestlers who just go
for it and just swing for the fences
you will see that sometimes uh you know
at like
collegiate national tournaments and
stuff there are some
really exciting wrestlers to watch no
question but you do get a lot of those
those match-ups at the really high
levels where it's just two people
who are never gonna give an inch who are
just perfect
and there's not gonna be an opening it's
somebody's gonna win
two to one you know um so wrestling
i've wrestled some people that actually
were like olympians
and like you know international level
talent
and i'm gonna tell you it wasn't fun
it's
it's fine to watch but man some people
are just some people are good at making
you hurt
as it turns out so yeah wrestling would
be the answer that like if you were to
tell me hey eric you got to
join a team or something right now i'd
say okay is there any wrestling going on
that's what i would do
but my my other answer of like what i
would be just
impossibly bad at but would love
i would just pretend i was being
competitive and do alpine skiing
i love going skiing it is so much fun i
didn't start until like maybe two years
ago
so i'm garbage at it but i i could go on
for hours explaining why skiing is
the best hobby it's perfect man i love
cold weather
i love snow you're outside i mean it's
always picturesque
it looks like you're like living in a
postcard
it's just the and there's like a little
physical component as well it's the best
hobby so
i would say oh yeah i'm a super
competitive skier and i would just
be last place at everything because i
suck sweet
what about you uh probably ping pong
so i'm i mean like i'm good
i'm not great uh if i'm playing
someone else who's like a recreational
ping pong player
i almost always win like i don't think
i've lost a game of ping pong
since freshman year of college but also
around that same time which is when i
was at my best
uh there were a few people who were very
good at ping pong so
there was this guy daniel who
man i'm probably gonna get canceled for
this he was from
somewhere in latin america and i can't
remember which
like i can't remember which country but
like he was from some latin american
country
and he was an alternate
for their like olympic ping pong team so
he never actually competed at the
olympics but he was like next guy
up if like their main guy couldn't do it
and uh so i mean like i know what really
really good ping pong players are like
and uh i probably played daniel
over a hundred games like we played so
much [ __ ] ping pong because like
next to daniel i was the next best
person in the dorm and so he liked
playing against me because i was the
only person who was
even close to challenging him but also
like
of the hundreds of games we played like
we played you know
to 21. i don't think i ever beat him and
i only
i think i only broke 15 like twice and i
think i only
broke 10 maybe like a dozen times
so just a completely different level so
i don't think i could ever be like good
good like international good at ping
pong
but i'm pretty good at ping pong and uh
i [ __ ] love it like it's so fun uh
it's
ping pong and basketball are the two
sports where
if there are people near my skill level
to play with
i will completely lose track of time and
would be
incredibly content just playing for an
entire day
and so yeah i can't say basketball
because that's one of
the big spectator sports so i i'd
probably have to say ping pong
yeah i've told you this story i had some
roommates in college that uh
they got a ping pong table and uh
they played all the time i mean
every day and i would i wasn't as into
it as everybody else so i'd jump in from
time to time but
they took such an exponential curve in
terms of their skill development because
they were i mean the practice was just
constant and so every time i like
checked in
and like played a game yeah i would lose
my mo
more and more and more and more until
eventually it was just like
this doesn't even make sense yeah why
would i pick up the paddle
yeah um now a related question here
what sport is the most fascinating to
you
or the most unbelievable to to reach
like a top level in
yeah so uh actually i want to go back
and clarify
my answer a little bit so i i flexed a
little bit and i flexed a little too
hard
okay um so it has been a long long time
since i've lost a game of ping pong
but i don't want to make it sound like i
play all the time like i've probably
played ping pong
maybe eight times since freshman year of
college
because i moved into a different dorm
without a ping pong table
and you just don't have that many
opportunities to play ping pong in day
to day life
unfortunately i went to a party one time
and see
some people were like oh let's play some
pong and i got super excited
turns out they were talking about beer
pong and i have never been
more disappointed in my life but yeah i
i mean so
like i'm super rusty i can still beat
other people who are very rusty
19 year old greg would kick the [ __ ] out
of me right now
um yeah ping pong's cool so okay
what sport is most fascinating to me or
most unbelievable to watch
at the top level uh so i have three
two of them might be somewhat expected
and the last one probably isn't
so i think the the most ridiculous sport
to watch
top level in is badminton because like
i've played badminton and i'm [ __ ]
terrible at it
which is crazy because like i like
racket sports like i'm not good at
tennis but
you know i'll go out there and swing the
racket and i
unless i'm playing someone good like i
can get the ball over the net like i can
keep a rally going
uh i'm pretty good at ping pong
badminton seems like it would be a
similar skill
set and it's just not like i'm trash at
badminton
and i don't understand how people can be
so good at it
and also just watching them not only do
they hit the
the shuttle [ __ ] super hard the the
the defensive players how are their
reflexes so good
like you're watching it on tv or like
streaming it
i can't even see the shuttle [ __ ] half
the time but like these [ __ ]
are reacting to it and like
you know digging it i don't know if dig
is the right term like that's what it
would be in volleyball
like they're digging it like 80 of the
time and i'm like how the hell are you
doing that it's outrageous
um so yeah i find uh top level badminton
fascinating and i can't even conceive of
how they're that good
yeah it's it's crazy i took a badminton
course
during undergrad in college and the
instructor
could not have weighed 105 pounds there
is no possible way
but i mean she was like a force
on the badminton court like you you
would just be afraid to even like
stand on the other side of the court
because she would hit it a thousand
miles an hour
i could i couldn't believe the amount of
power that she would generate when she
hit it it was
it was unbelievable yeah uh next would
probably be
gymnastics both male and female
gymnastics
uh takes so much strength
so much skill so much coordination um
like i i don't know what else there is
to say like top level gymnastics are
absolutely outrageous i have no idea how
they do what they do
uh and and the last one
this is probably the one people want to
expect is uh
super smash brothers melee competitive
melee if you've ever played
any smash game is outrageous because
like
uh the development cycle was rushed and
so there are
some facets in the game that like the
devs knew about but like didn't think
would be all that useful that they just
didn't patch out
uh and so like there's a lot of stuff
that's like
slightly glitchy but actually works
really well for top level competitive
melee
um and just like the actions per minute
that they're inputting to make the
characters do what they do
is [ __ ] outrageous um and like
i'm decent at uh
super smash brothers ultimate which is
like the newest game in the series
and everything after melee removed
all of those like high level options and
so like to be good at a current smash
game just doesn't
require as much motor skill as the old
ones did like it's it's more strategy
and like conditioning your opponents
like
it's it's more of a chess match whereas
like melee's [ __ ] trench warfare
and uh top level melee players are
so ridiculously good uh and also like
melee just runs on a faster engine
um like the whole game is faster uh fall
speeds faster
it takes it takes so much skill and if
you've never
played melee before you wouldn't have
any concept for just like
how [ __ ] good they are but like jesus
christ
top level melee is insanely entertaining
i'm going to be honest when i saw that
on the outline i assumed that
melee was some i assumed it was some
obscure sport
that i had never heard of but i was like
oh i'm going to learn something new
today this will be cool
i'm going to get uh you know enriched
with
some some knowledge of a maybe a sport
with some cool culture behind it
and uh i did not know melee was a video
game it is yeah but i mean video games
are sports these days right
they are yeah esports yeah fair enough
i'm not a big video game guy
i i is that the the game that i played
with you pre one one time
you made you played ultimate ultimate
okay well that that alone was
was a bit too much for me to handle um i
didn't do well
okay what are what are yours um yeah so
to me one of the things that i always
try to remind myself whenever i see
i don't watch a lot of uh what americans
call
soccer the rest of the world calls it
football
i don't watch a lot of it but when the
world cup comes around
you know you're gonna you're gonna tune
in whenever i see
someone who's a standout soccer player
at the international level i always
remind myself
the enormous talent pool
of global soccer players like to me that
that's the thing like
the probability of being good enough at
soccer with that global talent pool
to actually be a standout at the
international level
is really mind-blowing so for me just
the numbers behind that i i can
i never get over how incredible you have
to be
relative to the average person yeah you
know
another thing that the other thing i'll
add about soccer as well
is like uh when you think about other
sports that have
also really big talent pools i feel like
there's
a bit of i feel like there's a bit more
filtering
because like uh physically
soccer players i think do tend to be a
little bit
taller than average but they they tend
to not have like super extreme body
types
and so like if there's probably billions
of people who have tried soccer
it's not like there there's a filtering
process where it's just like hey
because you're too short you can't
possibly be good
uh and when so like probably the two
most popular sports in the us
are football and basketball maybe
baseball and i guess baseball would be
similar
it also doesn't select for as extreme of
a body type except for pitchers
um but yeah with basketball it's like
there's a lot of people that play
basketball but
in terms of making it to the nba you'll
occasionally see someone who's like six
foot six
one succeed and like there have been a
couple people who were five
something right like there was spud web
there was mugsy bugs but like
you can name all of them yeah which says
a lot yeah uh
but for the most part it's kind of like
you have to be this tall to ride this
ride like
there is theoretically a large talent
pool of people trying to get in but like
people who are six three are pretty
[ __ ] tall like if you see someone six
three in day to day life you're like oh
that's a tall person they are
considerably taller than most people i
know right but like they'd probably be
the shortest guy on the court
um and so yeah with soccer it's also
like
a it's a combination of the huge talent
pool and the fact that like
there's not as extreme of a filtering
mechanism
you know what i mean yeah and i think in
many countries
there's also not as extreme of a
filtering mechanism when it comes to
socioeconomic status you know there's
not a huge barrier to entry in the sport
where like
you know there are some sports where i
know at least in america it's like if
you don't have money
it's hard to really get your foot in the
door and play at a young age
so i think soccer is just so accessible
on so many levels
that yeah the talent pool is enormous i
have no idea what the
socioeconomics of soccer look like
around the world
i don't know us dude soccer's still a
[ __ ] expensive sport it is in the us
big time yeah americans have just
figured out how to make every youth
sport as
expensive as possible soccer is
expensive baseball is expensive football
was expensive when i was a kid
didn't you say you went to a wrestling
camp that was like thousands of dollars
that you knew about one oh there's all
sorts of wrestling camps like that yeah
the one i went to
was a little on the cheaper side but we
also slept on the mats
we were we were in a barn in july
yeah with no air conditioning sleeping
on the mats yeah so
it's hard to charge a premium for that
yeah i i mean like
so so you talked about how
like how expensive it is to get noticed
in some sports
i i mean like that's how sometimes like
great talent slips through the cracks
yeah like mike trout probably the best
baseball player today
um and if not like certainly the best
position play over
over the last decade or so you can make
a case for
for some other people like in this
season
uh but yeah incredibly good has been
good for a long time
was good from the moment he entered the
miners
but uh it was like his parents wanted
him to have a more
normal life and so i'm pretty sure he
did play
like au u triple s a ball but like
didn't travel to all of the big showcase
tournaments where like all of the scouts
were gonna be
and so you know when he was in high
school he was playing against good
competition
and [ __ ] murdering them uh but
you know because his parents didn't want
baseball to turn into like
a 30 000 a year sport for a teenager uh
he just didn't get the looks that he
could have and should have and like
you know now he has something ridiculous
it's like a 400 million dollar contract
so like he's gonna be fine
yeah but i'm sure that there are players
who
aren't quite as good as mike trout who
probably just like slip through the
cracks and don't get drafted don't get
the opportunities they should have
just because like either their parents
were unable to shell out that kind of
money and
it's a lot of money or we're just like
unwilling to because it's
it's like dude you're [ __ ] 14 i'm not
gonna spend
three grand every other weekend for you
to fly to some big showcase
yeah now i i will admit i've made some
assumptions when i was thinking about
socioeconomic barriers i was just
thinking do you have the equipment to
play ball
oh with soccer it's like no i i was i
roll out a ball
in the you know if someone in your
neighborhood has a ball everybody's good
no i i didn't like all of the scouting
infrastructure and
yeah and us sports yeah thinking of that
side of it i know soccer in america is
pretty expensive because they do a lot
of the big showcase tournaments it's
like
a lot but i don't know if that's the way
it is internationally
so someone will have to educate me on
that so i think that there are
i know at least in some countries there
are like development academies
and i have no idea what the process of
getting into one of those looks like
you know if it's just like open tryouts
or like if
the like payers parents have to like
play for them like it's a private school
um i could see that in some countries
being an economic barrier but i
i just don't i don't know what the
economics of development academies
look like yeah i have no idea but yeah
so soccer
i think is if you can stand out
that much with that many talented people
playing soccer globally i think that's
incredible
another thing that kind of blows my mind
is you know back in the day when i was a
kid they would play this on espn like
during the day in the summer but all of
the billiards type sports like you you
would turn it on and you would see
people playing pool
or playing like you know throwing darts
or bowling or something
those little skills that like you know
you go to a bar on saturday night
there's a dart board or a pool table
like
we all know how hard it is to do that
stuff
efficiently and when you watch like
you ever watched professional players
playing pool
they're very good if you miss you're
done
like generally uh yeah like unless you
hit a
awesome safety yeah if you're playing
like
eight ball or nine ball and like you
know you don't have a shot
you might be able to set up a good
safety yeah but i mean
it is it's not like when you're playing
with your buddy and it's back and forth
and back and forth it's like
if you miss a couple shots in a game you
can almost be certain that you lost that
game
like that the precision of you know
professional
dart throwers or bowlers or pool players
i just find that to be incredible
because
i've tried that skill and it is really
hard like i've tried all those things
yeah i don't understand how they're that
good at it okay have you ever watched
snooker
what is that uh so
someone might be about to come in and
correct me here but like
from from watching a little bit of it to
me at least it seems like pool on hard
mode
um so it's a similar thing like you're
hitting ball
you're hitting balls with a q and like
you're trying to like make them in
the pockets but like there's there's a
lot of balls going on
and like i think some of them have to be
hit in particular pockets and like i
think they have to be pocketed in a
particular order
and also if memory serves the actual
pockets are smaller on a snooker table
and so you have to be
even more precise um so
like i didn't even know snooker was a
sport like i don't
think anyone plays snooker in the us
like maybe
maybe in the northeast like i've i've
heard some of my family
from new jersey like reference snooker
before but like
no one plays snooker in the south uh but
i just so the the youtube algorithm
uh recommended me one time like
the best career plays of ronnie
o'sullivan who's like one of
the all-time snooker greats uh and i was
like
okay whatever i'll check this out what's
going on here
dude it was really [ __ ] impressive uh
so yeah if if you enjoy watching top
level
top level pool tracks you should uh you
should check out snooker at some point
i'll have to do that you know one other
kind of
random highlight reel that really caught
my attention that i didn't expect
if you've never watched sumo highlights
do
sumo is a very fun sport to watch
so me and lindsay were actually talking
about this
recently sumo highlights are fun to
watch
yeah i don't think i'd ever want to go
to a sumo tournament
why's that so i'm probably going to get
some of the details wrong here and
there's
there's probably gonna be some sumo
enthusiasts who uh
who who email us very upset but
i i think like the broad strokes of what
i'm about to describe are correct
so sumo highlights what you're seeing is
a whole sumo match
when someone's back hits hits the mat i
guess it's not a map but like when
someone's back hits the ground or
there's a ring out
like that's it you know they're not
doing best to five or anything
and so you see those highlights they're
like five seconds
maybe 10 seconds if it's a particularly
long match
that's it uh and then
with sumo like there's there's like a
ritual
that they go through before each match
and so like a tournament might have uh
like 30 sumo wrestlers in it um
and so there's going to be 15 matches a
day and they have to go through like a
relatively long ritual
every single time before the match
starts and so
you know a lot of people complain about
american football because
there's you know maybe six seconds of
action followed by like 30 seconds of
downtime
so sumo it's similar there's like five
to ten seconds of action followed by
like minutes and minutes of downtime
like way way more than the nfl
and a sumo tournament lasts for
i believe 15 days whoa so
i'm pretty sure there are four a year
um and like you know
for top level sumo i don't know about
like lower levels but for top level sumo
i'm pretty sure there are four
tournaments a year
each wrestler uh wrestles once per day
and it's you know five or ten seconds
and so
uh when last i checked the number one
yokozuna in the world was haku hosho
uh so if you're a big hakko hosho fan
you're gonna get like five to ten
seconds of action today
you're gonna sit through the rest of it
you come back tomorrow
you get another five to ten seconds of
hot sumo and sumo action
and then like you do that for two weeks
straight um
and also like you know how painful it is
to sit through the off season in
football it's like okay
you know there were yeah four or five
months
of games but like now i have to wait for
like six months for
football to come back yeah that's like
the life of a sumo fan
because you get approximately two weeks
of action and then you have a full off
season you have three months off before
sumo comes back and so like yes
sumo highlights are very cool sumo
wrestlers are
insanely good athletes but i think that
it would be very frustrating to be
uh like a huge huge sumo fan yeah
you'd have to develop a very different
level of just
patience with the sport yeah that'd be
challenging
um all right do you want to move on from
the realm of sports
let's do it do you want to you want to
skip this one and go to the next two
uh sure why not yeah let's go into that
this is an interesting question i i
have to assume we've at least kind of
touched on this at some point during the
podcast
but i made a youtube video about it back
in the day and people got
ass mad about it oh god
[Laughter]
why did they get mad so okay the
question is why we've stayed
steroid free or the prompt i should say
so why do people get
mad last time you talked about this
because the last time i talked about it
it was not
that long after i set my last world
record
and so it was just and this was also
like kind of at the peak of
fake natty hysteria yeah and people were
like mccarthyism
in the yeah yeah and so people were like
uh like you're just trying to deflect
like
the fact that you made this video counts
as an admission that you're
on a lot of [ __ ] um but yeah i don't
know
we'll see how this goes well this is
going to suck for me because no one's
going to believe that i'm natural
with my physique come on what uh so what
what are your reasons
you can kick this one off yeah so it's i
know i've mentioned this part on the
show before
um when i was like 18
i got to college and just ate everything
in sight
and lifted like most hours of the day
got some quick gains and i didn't read
much
at the time i assumed that that would
continue linearly
almost forever and so like i got in my
head at the age of about 18 and a half
like
i could be like a jay cutler lee priest
type physique um reality brought me back
down to earth eventually but
there was a moment there where i was
like what if i just leaned into this
hard
and just like said you know what the
drugs yes
whatever you're offering all of it i'll
take it and i thought about it and and
then did some reading
before it before i made that jump
because it's a pretty serious jump to
make
yeah um and for me it really just came
down to at the time
pro hormones were all over the market or
i mean they were just essentially oral
anabolics basically
but you could go the route where you got
you know the legal stuff
that was on the shelves at supplement
stores but that stuff based on
everything i was reading was like
awful for your liver yeah and i was like
um i know i'm young but like
i might live a while and i want to have
a liver the whole time yeah you know
and so that was like kind of i wasn't
really fond of that idea of doing the
legal stuff
and then the illegal stuff to me based
on what i was reading seemed like it
actually might be kind of the healthier
route
but i didn't want to be committing like
pretty serious crimes all the time like
i wasn't
i didn't think it was ethically or
morally wrong
as long as you're not like cheating
right so if you're if you're doing
steroids and then competing naturally i
do think that's an unethical thing
yeah but if you're not cheating anybody
in the process and you're just
you know doing steroids i didn't see
that as a moral
issue yeah but i was just like yeah i
don't i'm not comfortable with the
legal liability of you know obtaining
steroids all the time
i was also really put off i started
reading on forums and stuff that you had
to like actually
think about what you were doing like how
are you going to manage your cycle and
your you know
post psychotherapy and i was like dude
this seems like a lot of work
in thinking i don't want to do any of
that so it was a combination of
not being ready to become an amateur
endocrinologist
and not wanting to take stuff that was
going to just
wreck my liver and not wanting to take
on the legal liability
of having to actually obtain and possess
steroids as a controlled substance so
for me that was really it was it was a
matter of
the effort involved the liability
involved the potential health
ramifications and honestly the cost
i was a college student when i was at
the age of where i was like oh maybe i'd
think about it
i didn't have any money so even if i
even if the other things didn't deter me
i wouldn't have been able to afford it
anyway yeah so so that was pretty much
it for me what about you
so for for me the the liability was
definitely a big one as well um
so one of the things that i think
a lot of people don't consider is like
oh okay like if you're gonna do gear
what type of gear are you gonna do
and how much are you gonna do and then
like
it's it's one of those things where i'm
a relatively
extreme person by nature and so like
i know i know a fair amount of people
who
are on like just test and like a
slightly higher than trt dose of test
and by slightly higher i mean like two
or three times higher but
you know like a quarter gram or like 300
milligrams of test
per week which is like that's more than
people are putting out naturally like
they're getting some super physiological
stuff going on
probably building a little more muscle
than they otherwise would
almost certainly building more muscle
than the otherwise would uh and like a
lot of these guys are in their 40s and
like
they just found a very understanding
doctor that was just like yeah okay i'll
i'll write you a pretty liberal trt
prescription um
and with stuff like that one like you
know
it's not like there are no risks but
risks are constrained to some degree
uh and two if you were going that route
like basically
very aggressive trt test only route
and you were going through you know
black markets
then if you got busted you might
actually have
a pretty manageable liability so
if they busted you for possession and
especially if you have no priors
they're probably not going to come down
on you super hard um
but the problem is like i know myself
i'm an extreme person
if i were to do steroids for
powerlifting i would want to
instead of competing like relatively
near the top of drug-free lifting i'd
want to compete near the top of
untested lifting uh and like more stuff
is
generally good you know uh and so going
back to the liability thing
if you look at american drug laws
and how like the amount of steroids you
need to have
for them to be able to pin possession
with intent on you
it's like intent to distribute yeah yeah
uh it's it's less than a relatively
aggressive steroid cycle
like most people who are taking high
doses of stuff
if they're planning like a 12-week cycle
out if the feds
knocked on their door when they were in
like week two or three of their cycle
they'd get them for possession with
intent uh and that's
serious jail time and so like decades
right
it's it's a long time yeah yeah and so
you know for me it's like i i mean
i'm certainly not like opposed to trt
and like if someone just wants to run
a little bit super physiological to like
get a little out of it
their their liability is probably
constrained i don't see a problem with
that but like that's not me
you know like that's i think if i was
gonna go on i would go
on you know what i mean and so yeah one
of the big things for me is like i don't
want to get arrested and do
decades because like i just wanted to
get big um
so that was one of the things another
thing is um
there are quite a lot of heart problems
in my
family like heart issues are what kill
knuckles men
um and so like
i already have elevated risk for that
uh and you know
steroids uh generally increase your risk
of heart disease and so like
i don't need to further increase my risk
of heart disease like that's
that's one of the considerations um
that was one thing i wanted to add to my
statement the the way that i phrased it
made it seem like
the pro hormones were bad the steroids
totally fine i don't want to give that
impression
um there there are definitely some some
some health risks
even with the injectables uh another
thing for me
is like a lot of it's just like
curiosity to see what i can do drug-free
um so like i've i've had
i think i've talked about this on the
podcast before i've had these numbers in
my head for a long long time like i want
to squat and pull eight and i want to
binge five
and i'm just really [ __ ] curious to
see if i can do that without drugs
um and like from
i mean after i was in the sport for like
two years i've mostly lifted for myself
like i don't
uh like i'm not gonna play the uslp the
usapl game and like
go to nationals and like try to qualify
for worlds like
i just i have no interest in spending
thousands of dollars and like taking a
bunch of weekends and a shitload of time
to compete all the time like if someone
wants to go that route in powerlifting
i'm not going to yuck your yum
like you do you that's not why i lift
like
there are numbers i want to hit and i
want to hit them for me and so like
i don't want to take gear that would
like cheapen
those achievements for myself um so like
that is one of the considerations uh
another consideration
going back to health stuff um
is like
the fact that steroids are are illegal
means that like you have to assume
the risks that come with buying stuff
from the black market
and the thing is like just from talking
to people who are in that world
apparently like some people are
competent good procurers and
distributors of steroids and
but like when you look at the if you
when you look at the research of like
you know scientists go and like procure
a bunch of gear on the black market and
then test and see what's in it
one of the issues you can have is like
you plan out a cycle
you get your stuff your cycle's [ __ ]
because your stuff doesn't actually have
the stuff in it that you thought it did
you know um
so like that's that's one problem
another problem is like
a lot of the like a lot of the products
that one could buy via the internet are
like pretty heavily contaminated with
stuff
um specifically heavy metals so
you know a bunch of health problems
there potentially a bunch of brain
problems there
um so you know it's one of those things
where like
you need to it's probably not a world to
dabble in like you probably need to get
in deep enough
to make good enough relationships with
like
distributors that one could trust and
like
i didn't particularly want to venture
into
i mean i'm not saying it should be but
what it is now is essentially a criminal
underworld um
just because of how drug laws in the u.s
work i didn't want to have to like
venture in deep enough that i could find
a distributor that i trusted you know
like yeah if i was going to try
something i just want to like
be like i'm just going to dabble i'm
gonna buy something off the internet but
like i wouldn't trust stuff that i just
bought off the internet because those
are
risks associated with with operating in
a black market
um and then the last thing going back to
health risks
is when people think about health risks
associated with steroids they tend to
think
uh heart issues they tend to think liver
issues
um you know other like more vanity
related things that someone might think
about or is like baldness
acne uh like testicular shrinkage stuff
like that
the the potential side effect of steroid
use that scares me the most
personally is um there's some research
that suggests
that steroids have negative effects on
the brain and on cognition
so keep in mind here this is
cross-sectional research
you could never you you would never get
an rct
by an irb like if you're like hey we
want we think that steroids
we think that steroids might rot your
brain um
so we're going to recruit some people
and give half of them a placebo and half
of them
a dose of steroids we think that might
rot their brain and see if it rots their
brain like
no irb is gonna sign off on that but the
the cross-sectional research that's out
there
suggests that uh compared
to like matched controls that are
matched across as many variables as
possible
people who use steroids tend to have
lower brain gray matter
and like some some
like quantifiable aspects of
intelligence are lower so
you know not like every facet of
intelligence that one could
quantify but like some i think
specifically like verbal reasoning
tends to be a little bit lower um and so
the thing is like
you know i'm i'm not making a causal
statement here again there aren't rct's
like this is just from
from cross-sectional research uh but
it's enough to scare me
because i mean ultimately i make my
living with my brain
and i make my living by writing and so
like
if they do uh decrease brain gray matter
and if they do uh oh and i'll just note
as well like
it's not only cross-sectional research
like it is known
in from like in vitro studies that high
enough levels of androgens
can be neurotoxic it's also known that
like
some specific steroids primarily
thinking trend here trend is directly
neurotoxic
um and so like that that bothers me
you know um because ultimately i make my
living with my brain
and if i got a lot bigger
and stronger but was able to do my job
less well uh that would be great and so
that that is another thing that has kept
me away from steroids
yeah and i think it is important to say
you know like i i
i don't advocate for steroid use i've
never in my life been like hey you know
what you should do use steroids because
the the health ramifications and the
legal ramifications are enough for me to
be like yeah
not definitely not for me and nothing
i'd feel comfortable recommending to
anybody
but it's also like in the lifting world
some people use steroids
yeah i have zero problems with you using
steroids yeah i mean like
if you know the risks you're assuming
and you're not cheating
i have literally no problem with you
yeah i i want
to reiterate that as well uh
absolutely no problem with steroid usage
if you want to do it
do it i could not give less of a [ __ ]
um but yeah just not for me because you
know some people get this question they
they
kind of answer it from uh like a
moralistic perspective yeah like
oh i wouldn't possibly stoop to that
like it's not at all that like
like i said if you do steroids i have
literally no problems with you
you know as long as you're informed
about the risks you're assuming just
like anything like
i probably drink more than would be
optimal for my health
you know what i mean like based on the
numbers per week i'm probably a little
over what i should drink
yeah uh i know that risk i like bourbon
and beer that's how it goes
yeah you know so like i see it as the
same thing you know
well i mean so like
i'll i'll feel comfortable sharing this
i think
uh at some point once i hit the numbers
i want to hit
uh there's a part of me that kind of
wants to just like lean down and get
super shredded one time just to see what
just to see what it's like
uh what i don't want to do is i don't
want to deal with like
the uh the low energy induced
hypogonadism
that comes with like getting that
shredded and so
like an idea i've been bouncing around
in my head is like well if i go that
route
if things really start going south i
might just hit up an endocrinologist and
be like look
can you write me a trt prescription like
to finish this cut
because like dude you know it's one of
those things i want to see
what i look like to get super shredded
and i'm also
i think i'd be fine dealing with the
hunger like but a lot of the side
effects that we've talked about that
come with
natural bodybuilding they just sound
[ __ ] miserable
and i don't want to be a natural
bodybuilder like i don't want to
to live that life so like yeah i
i have already considered maybe getting
a little chemical
help to get there like not super
physiological levels but like
enough that like it's not like my dick
won't work for six months you know
and so like i i
don't think that that's dissimilar from
you know someone who just like for the
fun of it is just like let's see
how [ __ ] thick solid tight i can get
and they want to run a bunch of gear
like i don't i don't see a problem with
that at all
um so yeah now you mentioned that you
don't want to be a natural bodybuilder
have you put any thought into being
a natural classic bodybuilder
[Music]
uh no okay fair enough
um yeah i mean i'll tell you from from
being there
the hunger it's fine it's really not bad
the things that suck are like you said
the low testosterone
and the low thyroid hormone those two
things you're just
you're freezing all hours of the day
literally in the middle of july in north
carolina
freezing and yeah just living with low
testosterone is not a fun way to
live yeah at all so this next question
is kind of it's like kind of similar i
guess right
it's along the along the lines of
ergogenics sure
um so the question is if you could take
a pill to make you
smarter would you do it
yeah like i don't know i don't even have
to think about that
of course i would see i think you should
think about it so
it would depend on the side effects like
you know if it's like
you can take a pill to make you smarter
but then like you're gonna die in two
years like yeah
probably not but if it's just like no
strings attached you take the pill
you get smarter nothing else happens
like yeah dude for sure
so okay we we talked about this off air
a couple
like a few weeks ago which is
technically cheating but
um my initial answer was no
and you talked me out of it i will admit
you made some good points but i
my answer now is yes but i have some
reservations i still have some concerns
my question is is this just making me
smarter
or is it making me have like super human
intelligence
because i think those are two very
different things if something was making
me
smarter to like to a degree i could
control
like oh i'm gonna up the dose and go for
six capsules moving forward
like if i had some control over it i'd
like that but if it was just like
a thing that makes me super human smart
i think there would be some drawbacks
there
to some extent like i think if you were
that much smarter than every person
around you
i think that could lead to some
frustration like if you've ever tried to
teach something to somebody to somebody
that's just not getting it
if you don't really have the patience of
someone who's like
made to be a teacher it can be kind of
frustrating
and i do wonder if that would lead to a
lot of frustration if just like
if you were that much smarter than
everybody everybody around you i could
see that potentially being
a little bit annoying and i also wonder
if it would be
and i'm talking about super human
intelligence here i wonder if it would
be
difficult to socialize with people and
really relate the same way
if you were that much smarter so like
those are my initial thoughts and that's
why i was like nope i'm good
but you did talk me into it but i'm
still a little bit concerned about those
things
so so first i think uh
i think we need to operationalize some
terms what what does
it mean to be smarter like how are we
how are we quantifying analyzing that i
don't know
because like so from
so kind of like on a mechanistic level
if you're talking like general
intelligence a lot of that
seems to simply be how efficient your
brain uses energy and just like
how quickly it can churn through energy
um
because a lot of that relates to just
like
processing speed and power like a
a computer analogy is a bad analogy for
the brain but like that's what i'm going
with like that that ultimately
determines like your brain's processing
power and like
if your brain has greater processing
power um
one you can you can take in and
assimilate information
faster and then one of the
um one of kind of the hallmarks of
someone
with high intelligence like one of the
things they can do is they can
contain more information in short-term
working memory
and and manipulated better essentially
so
uh you know for example someone with
really low intelligence
yeah i'm not talking like someone who's
just learning math but someone who just
has like low intelligence might really
really struggle
to add a one-digit number to a two-digit
number where you need to carry a one
because like you need to keep the two
numbers in your mind you need to
like keep the carrying the one in your
mind and like that's
that's like four or five like bits of
information that they need to have in
their mind that they need to be able to
work with and manipulate
uh whereas someone who i think there are
actually like tricks to do this like
multiplying big numbers together but
assuming you don't know the tricks
um someone with like crazy crazy high
intelligence
might be able to multiply like two seven
digit numbers together uh with like the
same
the same ease and speed that's it might
take someone else to like add
two three digit numbers together which
is something that like
most people can do but does take a fair
amount of mental effort
um and so like that's that's ultimately
kind of what's going on
with high intelligence like you can you
can assimilate information and like
manipulate more pieces of information in
your working memory
or manipulate the same pieces of
information in your working memory
faster like that's
that's there there are other facets of
intelligence but that seems to be like
one of the biggest ones i'm concerned
because i'm particularly bad at the
things you're describing right now
i don't like that we can cut that from
the episode
so here's my d have you ever looked into
it into any research
like are intel are more intelligent
people
generally happier or more content
have you ever seen research on that i
don't know about that uh well
so
it kind of depends on what you're
talking about because like it's hard to
disentangle
a lot of factors right um so
people who people who have like outlier
intelligence
ten it tends to be associated with
higher rates of min of some mental
illnesses
um but then the question is like you
know
is it is it that there's like an
underlying factor that might be causing
those two things and that like
the intelligence itself isn't related to
the mental ill
illness at all but there's right yes a
common factor causing both of those
right
that'd be very hard to try to untangle
that yeah yeah
another thing is like i think happiness
generally tends to increase with
intelligence up to a particular point
but earning power tends to as well
and so like that's also difficult to
disen to disentangle like
like the the socioeconomic comfort level
right yeah like what what is causing
what there
yeah and so like yeah i don't know i
don't know if you could
strictly ascribe causality to anything
going on there
right yeah so that's kind of my thing is
like
i would definitely like to be more
intelligent than i currently
am i just worry if if you became that
much of an outlier you know if this
hypothetical
pill gave you like super human
intelligence
i wonder if that might be a bit more
isolating
and a bit more frustrating than you
might initially think
i i wonder if the when you are like
truly
outlier super human smart if you would
if you would regret that decision to
take this fictitious pill
i mean i don't know so i think the
biggest question for me is like is it
reversible
like is this a pillow it's not it's not
i think i'd still send it
fair enough man yeah no you definitely
talked me into it i just
you would you would dive in head first
and i would
cautiously wade into the scenario but
i'd still probably take it
i think those are just like
generalizable facets of our
personalities
yeah that's that's true that's
definitely true all right let's uh let's
shut it down
well uh thank you for listening
to this the eighth installment of the
stronger by science fireside chat
series um yeah thanks for tuning in
if there are any topics you'd like us to
address
you can fill out a form located at
tiny.cc
sbsqa to submit those questions or
topics if you like the show
feel free to rate it on itunes or
you know wherever you get your podcasts
if if you don't like it
uh you can also rate it that's fine i
guess but please don't
and if you're listening on youtube like
comment subscribe it really does help
and that's about it hope hope life is
treating everyone well
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now
greg and i are not experts in medicine
or health or
really anything else for that matter so
before you make any changes to your diet
and exercise habits make sure you check
with a doctor
or another health care professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it
visit strongerbyscience.com to check out
the products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you